أجنبية
[موسيقى]
المياه للحيوانات التي تركتها
سفيتلانا تسحب بعضًا منها كل أسبوع بينما
تنتظر إمداداتها الخاصة
أو بالأحرى قراها، فالأمر
خطير جدًا على خدمات الطوارئ لذا
ستحملها بقية الطريق
لا أستطيع التخلي عن الناس  تقول
كبار السن وتقتبس من الحقبة السوفيتية
قائلة إن لم تكن أنت فمن، ولكن حتى في
وسط ستيبنو جورسك لم يبق
الكثير من الناس، الروس على بعد
خمسة كيلومترات فقط من
المباني السكنية مثل هذا المبنى الذي كان على
خط المواجهة  هذه الحرب منذ ما يقرب من عام
ونصف،
ويقول القصف إن العدد القليل من السكان الذين
بقوا هنا ليلًا ونهارًا،
حوالي خمس إلى ستمائة مدني بقيوا
في هذه المدينة من عدة آلاف
قبل الحرب حتى الآن، ويقولون إن
الهجوم المضاد لم يحدث.  لقد جعل الأمور
أسوأ بكثير من حيث القصف ولم
يقولوا إنه جعل الأمور أفضل، إنه أمر
خطير كل يوم، كما يقول سينينكو بين عشية وضحاها،
تعرض سطح ذلك المنزل للقصف، وكان هناك قصف بعد
ظهر أمس، واشتعلت
النيران في المبنى في اليوم الآخر
أثناء قيامنا بالتفتيش  الضرر الذي أحدثته
نيران المدفعية الليلة الماضية، طائرة روسية بدون طيار
تتفحصنا وتنفجر فور مغادرتنا
ولكن على مراحل قليلة، يقول ميكولا مالكين، خدمات الطوارئ المحلية
التي كانت ترشدنا حول
الناس الذين اعتادوا على الحرب،
قبل أن تقاطعه قذيفة
أن هؤلاء خدمات الطوارئ  لا يمكنها
الاعتماد على أشخاص مثل سفيتلانا، فسوف
تمشي الآن بما يمكنها دفعه على
دراجتها لأكثر من ساعة نحو نيران العدو،
ولكن مع كلبها تقول
إنها لا تخاف أبدًا